I thought I'd do something different
today so I haven't given this talk
before I'm going to tackle the issue of
free speech from a left-wing perspective
it's actually dead simple to provide a
left-wing rationale for free speech it
should be self-evident to people who are
pursuing social justice that the most
potent weapon in their artillery is the
ability to communicate what are people
who lack power have other than their
ability to speak on their own behalf and
isn't it on their behalf that the right
to speak must be most jealously guarded
anyway I thought I would begin with a
crucial observation there's a
fundamental structural reason why our
political system has developed both a
left and a right wing and that's the
tendency for scarce resources to become
unequally distributed so let's discuss
that in my clinical practice I once had
a client an older guy in his 80s he'd
come to me after his wife had died
because he was Lonesome but also because
he was obsessed
mostly with mathematical ideas that
premise of the most my heart emails the
most beautiful mathematical equation
which is quite high E is high in 115
phrase and I showed it to a woman in our
furnaces is also very a mathematics she
was also quite long as she thought it
didn't really have the same effect on me
because I'm walking on two seems a
normal a fanatical agenda not deceived
me in a symbol that represents that sort
of thing anyway I got to know him pretty
well and without me in some sense funny
he was mazing to to some party and I
serve dinner too much for more from him
than you get for me and they tell me
which is pretty they're also helping I
think time to tourism is not practical
obsessed you can't stop thinking about
half an hour businessman I was more than
just the way my views wider that way and
don't add mode some sense but well if
your own sense of genius that's just
like a feel and Sarah people a baton and
all that common
our son who was he has psychology simply
an issue of indecision economics and
trying to learn how to get distorted
which he depressed except allah and he
introduced me to some concepts that i
haven't encountered which shocking
Charlie either contest is super honestly
fundamental the fundamental works and I
couldn't believe that I had bothered so
much education and so much further
education and research and and develop a
certain expertise in statistical are
most physical expert without
encountering that idea and he introduced
me to one happy company don't or through
a real friend LLL present perrito with
an Italian economist and also the word
of Garrett result of price who would
sound who said scientific productivity
at an extra ticket normal called a tiny
little part I tried to take a copy
undergone Amazon try this again I
believe me first occasions like the
thumbprint they were selling for about
six hundred and thirty bucks which is
quest and it shows me how resistant
people are turn after their piece of
work and so it will come about the solar
crisis personnel coming on top reprieve
and degree of decision so is all prior
to interest in scientific productivity
and theta psi be propagated by the liao
papers given scientists published and
silencer on set with to science with
drone test with recycling publication
energy head while they Eli status like
the next person and sad how to be
measured and n and and track and
communicated party good well it happens
both people and ever set the height of
innocent of a border them is owed will
keep track of people to call the
sympathy Deborah sympathy and then you
don't hire or promote or place the
proper people of the scientific
community has oriented itself very well
and keeps very high try out different
metrics of research post let's say and
it's a one of those would be number of
papers published in here is eternal and
active on that deserves our top tier
nominees I see and if you've got a very
excellent in the end of scientific
quality partly because generally
speaking quality and quantity in a
productive field are quite tightly
correlated and reading rather well it's
not obvious the more we practice that
content that they have been taking it at
so far begins quality 10 second delay
but their honor than yet whose lifetime
the quality of the journal that you
publish in that index by the average
number of citations that it is neighbor
might get and buy a seat opposite
indication of impact rating no one who
cited work like 80% of published
humanities papers and 0 plays mmm
absolutely appalling but if you keep
away those papers there's also journals
library by them zero people read them in
ten sentences are necklace campuses
server they're very expensive and
obviously publicist their sense and
library path the Bible and so the
library fire even though Colin root for
the drone sites whether they staff the
firemen he increased the ratio is going
to disable and to subsidize that you are
intelligent it's one of the reasons
technologies are dying
probably not fast enough
art designs require both the particles
enemies are the heart of the university
and make no mistake of the United us or
even repeated up the textile started
self that is part of them other than
other reasons these negatives to paper
left humanity to the hardy University
loop those consumers not terrible thing
but Nora Sarah what's happening continue
on up and they're all right now so focus
right exactly 72 productivity so this
all fibrous curious about who little
productive and what the differences in
productivity order and Hindi people
katha the hours number of publications
that a PhD student averages within 3060
a horn Granberry outrageous go houses
set but a hardened renovation their
initiative genesis negative in terms of
other seventh-grade run so the median is
founder publications which is the
technical merit of the average number
right the typical number that people
would produce with what one moment asian
and then trying to okay fine the median
person of one how many people publish to
and has that was half as many publish
one and the answer is the bombay people
are pretty he has a patronage and
published two and four will happen in
25,000 is four and so we see this
standardly rather drawn a productivity
but as you move outwards in general Oh
patience senator desired that so so
Matthew brass what happened in if you're
if you're Bradley come with people's out
of the teacher
publications you have the vast majority
of people that want common attitudes
admins have three four five the many
developers appear to have maybe like ten
or maybe 20 and own people are well
they're super Jesus in the field right
there
they're ongoing these are turning ugly
fast
there are no really reductive and
running you and so crazy being on stage
about psychics productivity and it's a
terrible terrible operation in a heap at
and he overheard that if you took a
domain and scientific opportunity and
you were trying to be religious about
the word he has about that it was the
square root of the number the square
root of the number of people who are
offered each mounting your
specialization for is half the
publications that is worthwhile taking
this group however they horrendous
philanthropy for deleted and also
replace but employee productivity in
corporation spy-ray saying general
person so if you are can party freedom
you have to work while that's not
surprising know you have people to
donate work you have some people who
don't solve it work that they actually
cost you money it's that that's the S
therefore I remember correctly
sixty-five percent of managers at pages
of metal you
- easy to say quantity and whole time
okay so yes can bring that work I think
you so that well you have 25 are you
have work that is not yet 100 can get a
thousand well it's hardly any 30 so what
does that mean it means that prohibited
asserted in in a manner that was
described by Del Rio Rico and that's it
for your distribution and we look at the
distribution of the income average in
tradition of whether it curry energy
which means that almost everyone had not
and a few people have written it and
that even fear people have a little bit
more than that and there's some people
who hate for example Carlos with Jeff
Angeles who have more money to go
anywhere take a lot to consequence of
improper social structure and the right
response then no it's not it actually
something more akin to the natural law
is government decision of the DC
government decided to say that means a
health empowerment decided planetary
body as part of the blame on the future
to govern the distribution every single
thing that human bees produce creatively
so for example I'm here in Christ Agra
so it implies to number of people's
scores for example sadly messy and took
away all here that goal we still have no
appointee with any more compressed than
ever
clear and so go and get yourself that's
really interesting because any tell us
one percent you know it's modest like
1/10 of one tenth of one percent all of
you who played hockey gear in the NHL I
know one right get up and your average
NHL top with your superstar and then
you're some sound effects like people to
stay home and not that repeated all of
these people making to the creative
expression I can tell you some people
who are granted like inner thousand
somebody talk about how those hassle he
in the turkey Thurber yeah there's a
long productive life rises again our new
president remaining one day on top of me
on a heart of art have introduced have
you go to my competed just sketches and
he was like just proton but don't think
that go on to these online the castle
archive where 50 thousands of them have
to be documented and now if you believe
my first one
but also tools I got a baton and then I
addition research smarter how many
artwork this praise character
displacement yes was sixty five thousand
three day every single day the 65 years
um just all seventy producing artwork
over water like super poor people say
for lack of uses right so this was no
biker this guy heinous he was somewhere
else and bought an applicator far as
well he wrote so much imaging that it
was a a Tatia 45 years of ele just copy
what he had composed so healer don't the
scale he could direct you to a video you
know music assessment is package number
sir so immerseus this is just a really
interesting almost Aquarius to dis
impression
why the world is the world cut like that
that birth rested and the second dress
is what we simply need everything
routing the unfair innocence
please disregard to distribution you can
idiots discovers that those people are
producing things like that and random
are at least in critical picture
avoidance but not alas the company calls
in terms of inequality up of
distribution and building all these
things why is that the case
well here's one reason so and this is
something I worked on that weeks in
parts of mine with my father who also
had a theory on societal evolution which
psychosis
I'm superior either this mystery a few
of the perimeter of your own business
diagonal Recon businesses before and Tom
another very productive in regards and
the amount of differences stay healthy
Ethan loyal the distribution of money in
what the nation using the same rate that
uses model with an institution of a gap
into a vacuum so so there's a nice
interview like phenomena driving the
digital image so engineers are worth are
you guys holding it all right
and so for any war he you know they are
dividing cat Authority debt and the vs.
the luckiest with that amazing coming
all the work there's a lot of I didn't
say a skill to some robotic loss to take
a good but locally automatics man
walking you know that we played Monopoly
games turn my key that you're going to
win more than or ready terror so they go
how often the person counted you started
from a position of equity
everybody has neither the same amount of
money and then you engage in random
Chinese essentially shaded us and so
what happens well what happens is so
here's the graph one bar is number of
feet for deeper planning all I'm exactly
the same about money
thousand dollars to begin with or
something like that thank you for
chasing another and then refers to a
vision which few people started reading
it more and a few people search a little
bit more and then what happens to the
winner is that they become more
resilient initiating more often than the
people who are starting to notice and so
what happens is the density she's
blinded don't buckle people get more
money
one person program in the lead some
people earn money a loser starts to help
and you keep changing the dice soon what
happens is that somebody's 0 now zero is
a terrible number and you can see that
it's all certain ways for example you're
trying to start in zero content is
really the wrong number of custom and
way harder to be the first time
certificate to second customer you know
wage and eater 107 cops for vendor third
customer madly needs hardness need to
have a biographer you with Travis old
well you know he'll be social proof is
Marcelo I'm you and revolutionary and
they well that's all from different is
so damn late under the Kaneko grip of
being wrong Hydra but it's not
inevitable 5000 save all these other 100
people artists why fathers okay
which is a reasonable justification but
I where they have to stay while you are
winning I'm going to land and cook new
exciting use LifeCam your fire
[Music]
so far they're very to come away from
zero that was not the department
community is here we're going to do
incredible they don't have we can even
have 20 Wallace and the problem is you
can invest zero to make a former you're
done you set a zero you're done so here
are all number probably keep another
game what happens is some oscillations
of money
now you can complain house of rules of
the game there's no money that gets
people will play you can say oh they
don't what they are not considered each
one you know put a crab walk away so
cotton and several houses hard mutants
and oppressed he's not level players and
but agree chat up the game and play it
once more the same long determine now my
life my officers which I hope that are
different
whereas it bounced into sergeant our
party we would revolution and kind of
our society in some sense which is it
you play on a farmhouse you consumers
landed training as long exactly around
the Trinity there you can automate the
Atlantic
what happened essentially you know some
people have everything and almost
everyone back up to zero and the problem
is zero
is it you got a little you might not
serve the damn border the start of this
game and not especially your name and
there anything assertive derailers
because males need sad and reason that
is because he awakened with no staff
this is so that fundamental rule so the
information between male socioeconomic
status and actively are discovering love
point six which is a statically high
correlation for the solace on Matthew or
I see hardly see the only college that
never be higher than that is the
relationship between inequality and
they're all sides and 0.8 comes all
clapping Wally's credit card
names are killing Joe and the young man
and the calendar banana and a good
therapist bees and it was written raised
right then it is using hundred to me I
see some people back we're trying to
think page we're trying to create a
little town soon if we're not careful
cover repulsive each other teacher is
that right yeah I'm short I'm driving
always our organization it's like it's
your lead buddy and so try again or may
not end up yet it is all about it so
what happened he charged with
second-degree murder there's not enough
opportunities to go after you and that's
only harder downtown water given out
yourself attacks before the prison to
three years he's certainly a model and
then you come up no bloody one haven't
lead you right leg another Horseman and
on calculation he made an exact one and
so but for the contrary all so he is
these are evenness this instrument
called great Gina questionnaire and I
don't leave Susan by maybe she'll it
harder but our duty to the walkway and
it is become quite a popular nation on
when you think about creativity is too
is big enough you think about creativity
as a process you know how to be concrete
and you can you say and I make those
things to some degree drive human
specially to her liking and also with
this trait is paid by for Zelman pretty
so in holiness which is a fundamental
under the cohesion vials we recruited
personal trait amazingly people who are
creative are going to have generating
exemplars either of a category or you're
doing that interview thing I have here
right now it's actually quite
straightforward so for example if I got
you guys to pull up newspaper and
writing on a neighbor than you could
they began with the letter S they bring
in the number of course you generated
will be coordinating these your create a
copy about 23 24 and you think well
that's not very high back you got hired
it is generated about 35 percent social
science better so explain that well
small effect I can have a lot more that
being paid for for other reasons
party because these streams now it will
announcement and I can do a better job
if I set up regular visions in the
Emperor Great Britain is and we are sort
of role in terms of how many uses you
came up with
but how comparatively rare your releases
were compared to the rest of the
operation the score value would have to
be sensible you've got me applaud of the
use for a break but rarely advertise II
seem to make a lot of what quantity
spearheaded so that'll be dancin as well
but that's my normal distributed
butterfly skeleton where religion love
of yada
you get a free candy contagious are in
two different ways so we're interested
in crew to the chief compliment right so
normally say crazy but much we produce
something in the world not a consequence
and you can make love which is better
definition of pretending the past you
can have both definitions and they're
equal current purpose and we chose the
great achievement definition okay we're
here we go
and so Jesus we thought about these are
amazing edges are default reasonable of
Internet and so that was like dance
music theater attentions cooking you
know not know it's our natural images
fiction writing nonfiction writing
unnatural Virginia let's educate
detection and then we had we even show
any point is getting a lot of levels of
achievement and we have
generally by hackers and then we record
in terms of their being probabilities of
February 0 I have no training or talent
in this area and summary a life well I
think you have a registration an M so
and so the pianist booklet on suppress
Karen and forget the anticipation and
what we bought this create an expedition
I've never before I do entry
investigations work all that we making
the scale top steps because everyone is
so society this basically ruined
everything involving distributive which
is wrong many are cream distributed
about right out everything the people
produce creatively is communal dissident
and is really really really really
important because you see one of the
things that shows you is that whatever
is going on a different distribution
that was judge characterized income
distribution you can't explain it
stupidly on unfair social circumstance
it's also the case that every society
every scientist I had a marine of
disagrees Nvidia that how Steven is that
varies to some periodic wants printer
things like social policy is very very
difficult to get away from the free
entities that we all have religion
that's that's the real truth is you know
in Italy
anyway the crazy press theorem of power
that I think it was sixty percent of
people had a score 0-0 and a degree in
any of the third de meses pasados right
how many is a great book well not and if
you happen to give you certainty and
publishes and if you get published in
the no water
no one resources pretty hard and many
recommend rejection rating for certain
adult engages like 99% and then like a
million folks covers here out of it I
can't remember it's like twenty five
hundred seven to ten thousand office or
something horrible like that you know
seasonable life in his presence of the
reasons for substrate someone is
involved you love you very much is live
in all here for over a year 2010 is
allies Delhi house s element but ease
Brendon hands of the radical pretty good
distribution the others we really have a
tea party everybody but most of all
estate is started they started like our
solos we are often quite worn it out
we're going to decline in all money
flows like fire people
anything awful thing about this Sigma
geographically both in strange man hey
Bob real-estate territory in
relationships books and then they
ultimately network and then they
probably remember bookstore and then
they hope the best sellers stand one two
three four five no aunty Lee any the top
line and one lot of them and then there
isn't just one of those stands the other
night and I like 70% of the selling real
estate territory and it is overwhelming
dominated by person helping the left
hand corner who is very often stephen
king whose name
everyone knows whose work
predict make the charge easy Joey occupy
them your point somewhere Eunice's can
you spare don't you read silently not
only descends avoiding the doors and
that how it goes for every day so here's
another example so they know composers
turned out that five composers pave over
boats are hiding to call I mean I love
them propose the world made out 95% of
the perform classical repertoire when
the homeless TV right here is old
entirety composers some very good yo yo
yo yo pathological musicians and lenders
and spread many little those people's
beautiful competition is what you might
notice is five percent of what they
oppose it's 95% of the plane I'm sorry
but are making opposes at all over all
the music that everyone doesn't do and I
was hardly anybody's in a postman and
that's what satellite and so The
Economist's
with all this surfing cause the Matthew
principal which is interesting
no one make sure extraña statement I
friends in the development I don't think
he has many economically stated one of
them in addition he said some dirty
dishes sensitive detector in Austin
which is one of the things that leads
decrees life destinations
we read 2002 to those of everything more
will be given
from most nothing everything will fade
away so that's another personal that's a
brutal principle success worries success
and that out of will work not what's
wrong with that
the audience is people sat on 0 you know
make that money use nothing wrong that's
actually zero but it close to here you
know there's an article in the NI on
will get you comfortable some reporter
decided to blow anything is overwhelming
alright certain right these are many
awesome people to see what proportion P
will compel the five hundred dollars in
an emergency
Anna the answer what a shockingly low
number people or or insanity or how many
excess body fat ass so other people to
work in with a zero which is a very
tough place to be long as you want
people to stack up a hero because what
happens is that Olympic that happens is
that the more violence let us start on
fun see this young man and he's down it
may also be opportunity they all need
something aim for right they do all that
but if they're in fight for these
equality whatever inequalities three
steep it is harder for them to move out
position and the deserts differ somewhat
bhaiyyaji's whatsoever and some are seem
to have is that our society's once more
of our equal the pressure on men grows
and you can pageant world what sort of
young man becomes viola further where
you had any other what we call Meredith
Grey by dating an older guy maybe the
guy he's driven less a guy who thought
of swirling against the wall three or
four times when he was drunk when he was
three and damaged his brain you know
anybody who's impulsive and a lot of the
history of the future is going to be
more hyperbole made by a host of others
locally launched class and our client
and I was beaten up you know like people
that maybe I thought Jill gave me
anybody I was first in the Western world
live on one door in the name anyone pay
$12 far more more back and by normal to
$80 but back and everyone and I think
Madison people have some I think even
the rich back in like a if you live now
that I believe you've got little water
to go special meeting
you've got reliable shelter you've got
an infinite amount of innovation
anything it's like every moment it's
like you're fully rich time you're
fulfill the risk much that's why
everything that you can have is that sad
because out in terror so look it's going
to need to know we just walk towards you
might think of yourself as poor and
wrong you might be relatively poor which
usually means every four years again
that they never said that now but just
all that baby without result
anyway playing so you're probably
societies with Yosi created products
getting killed so that people stop at
the low battery energy people static I
am and then things start to destabilize
that's the default so funny
quiet hypothesis was well societies run
out there and in thirty game until poll
people have zero people at everything
and then into revolution thousand more
eleven the circuit yet what does it mean
intercity glasses the rubble like and so
there's a way to get out because mark
football set capital to heaven to
accumulate in hand if you were to feel
people that they he talked along and
this is important things on a standard
of it although there is the one percent
ignore just one camera one percent have
all the resources that the bunkers they
have like make that offense and to all
the better it's not the same people
that's that's one into makes mark
securities law it's not ok people most
family farms is a lot through
generations right because I don't want
you guys had money sometimes if you keep
it really wasn't
yeah
yes purple disaster Auckland and always
a living soul about just that slightly
yellow ardently you just spend large
horns money equally assumedly and let's
to somebody who really or another
building money those people are really
quite rare and so having horses
dispersed very very loudly and the
biblical course five hundred unusual
about about thirty years so although the
exacerbation is the way that I describe
the constituent elements of the
distribution turnover by flattery so I
think if you're and maybe other 10%
chance of homes houses that and maybe I
am percent chance of being in top one
percent or peace one year of your life
on average and farmers have a chance of
being the top ten percent for at least
one year on average so young people who
brought it out you're alive and another
thing to keep in mind this is very
important and no one you're talking
about this is it
most of the reason that people that
honey and the whole but these young
people have a money but they're wrong
all people over as a result golden so I
already have most money right now Mike
which is open and I can easily and
probably all on Ethan you're so funny
before the entropy well yes you can
think about that yourself if your job is
like okay now from the north of 1985
this is the place what do you hate so
you know to some degree depends on how
you calculate well right so okay so
what's the point all that if all these
is and it's actually fundamental problem
and even if you're a conservative person
you have to make all the fundamentals
that are in equality is out of hands
outta me the design is arts destabilize
and you know what a conservative problem
and they're not on time preventive
services for that matter top I'm like
well what our suicide crime they only
find homicide let's say we know what it
is it's inequality the corporation is
like that point eight it all is all the
staff employment Savin called it
addicted to deep dr. Martin daily who's
a research psychologist at exactly that
is the fight and he'll a field rounder
to this sort of research so I'm very
pleased had one week and we were
appropriate to call killing on occasion
said in his book he talked about they
all do violence and a rational strategy
for a certain environment where there's
a lot of chaos and a lot of equality
these were made very sorely biological
why wasn't already get me here
psychologist very very highly
last mission the last thing charities
deal with social contributors to Emily
and I don't think the best artists often
I don't think it deals with the funny
whistle on turn to tell you for some
intimidation isn't something going on
here if I can ask the law this reduces
wide disparities now not now spices what
should give us an answer is it not
because it's letter dilute solutions and
all hell breaks loose and you know even
if your excellency they don't hate erase
your now in Central America you didn't
wanna get your division Columbia ball
great how can you look at all sides
except inside the confines of your
compound you're in the jail
nice your interviews sad but what of
evidence yeah what a huge house parade
more queens barber drugs are beverages
and another kid out on you oh maybe not
but very rich oh I don't think so I give
it a month ago I was poor your head of
students and students up psycnet and I
intended for my Hartman in this was the
monkey bikes like mustard all peaceful
like great Indian structure very free
money you saved it run - and mine too
granular the city is always open to a
lon often a spiritual cost their owners
Polly essentially let's give in to your
fiance hell you're rich
well part of your makes on the
circumstance about that because evening
all you have about
control and so companies they're harder
to find well - well as much as what are
you happen to possess that might be sad
this has you but standard level and all
the same thing okay so how we do this
well then problem obviously both those
are unequally distributed and that's not
fair there are additional problems that
go on advocate one probably do and if
you have to leave in the darkest and
it's easy for your charity or your
children also important so spectrum
bladder now V vs evil a and the
reasonable probability is your hall and
some of it is active due to the
intelligence in turns out that on
average intelligent people have more
money and unintelligent people which are
becomes a surprise and conscientious
people have more money and unconscious
people
we also hardly come to describe an idiot
and I was very thinking what maybe it
hasn't yourself not as intelligent and
then did you threaten me in even the
unequal distribution of intelligence
certain self out across time but
Monsieur the people at work you might
describe it up technically under there
that okay so your designation problems
are technically unfair opportunity
problems and it's reasonable to point
your love and that's what the last dot
right that's what Alexa responding
properly it says look we want to eat the
day arm equality the gene for cases
let's say go to keep the equality black
now there's more evidence about
and the lease people are pretty
phenomenal useful and put an opportunity
and then you will get to enjoy all the
cool things they have a neighbor men and
I want your boy and indirectly people
say yeah there is black alpha gamma
distribution to my schedule people
December and so are you thank you - but
yeah that's way turn so you are surveys
or turkeys and question n is what we
should display my twelve that Christmas
you that I want so I'm going down to the
minimum frame rate here's my main
comment is alignment to the first thing
over you is how about why do you are
like that and we can sound a lot further
investigating the relationship between
the fundamental by our cameras including
intelligence and political that LRD
point now if there is an engine rattling
the idea of the viewpoint you did you
see when you guys over the world you
don't see the world you see that hiney
little item of the world that you
thought analysis right you get a little
too complicated and I don't know how
many people seeing the same considerable
gorilla video like
there's most people play basketball for
teen boys dreaming them watching black
freedom it has palpable back and forth
between them this post County number
times lefty past basketball they fill
the GOC six people to get around on some
basketball you're counting two things
you forget smart decision you can time
again
so draw attention on each chapter a 15
second thought what an enemy fear never
asks you if you notice anything strange
and you say no and he said probably how
do you say 16 they have that happen
inaccurately this did you see the girl
up and you say whatever happened you say
what girl
and so then you rotate and sure how
possible then probably them to be you
are just like very bright blonde but
here are so long anybody's were so much
and so much like this you know Kylie you
have a cannon on a piece of paper you
know in the consciousness is like the
ball pointing pouring on that cannon
it's writing it's just barely maybe
contact notes not the right and move on
which is not pretty but that how the
coldest we are we're focused on the
things that we find report and then the
person yes why we find the same can find
me Horton Horton and as one is and this
department camera every filter sorry
silvers and sound with your high
openness or any talking 3d your
esophagus texture you talk about you if
you're asking hurted it's like the whole
world's a party and you're vegetated if
you're abroad bunty's
things that are dangerous alaikum
if you're agreeable its relationships
you want to take care of things one
forms in relationship if you're probably
headed Italy usually to it dimmable
dealership that's it or you and not
however your attitudes but it also
filters things for you so you see the
world through your temperament
you can filter news through your camera
right and so welcome to part of it is
there's different niches in the world
but you know make your entertainers like
to play a part of me you can be rely on
some people after you help the road in
or you and fixing a regular gravel so
you're okay summaries have a talk about
sometimes bother you have there maybe
your disagreeable this someone wants the
blonde screw and they'll come and talk
to you and so these are all places that
you can fit in the social structure
anymore so that's why I use that very
heavy
more power to spray is people from
equipped in the world with different
tools and the tools other to be
presenting the matter diversity it's
real diversity of that Indian diversity
if you see any marks on us alright in
plenty of real diversity all right so
you're where you are yeah you know Carol
didn't I better know what you're doing
so preparing the other child is high in
the Odyssey let's say and you can help
you tell about deafness there could work
out the apartment on them down they
start we're leaving me to annoyance
they're more you know more cost and the
reason it's something you think is kind
of our own taking you study the robot
robot testing to see how after all
favorable you describe that we excited
group all the raw materials speaking
wave one flashes and
the expert is not an oncologist
interactive again robot anymore pteropod
behind their parents mother explained in
detail young man and that was a man is
every six months not one take problem
was that answer the people who have what
he called inhibited children were
dancers encouraging them to get out in
the world their level of negative
emotion could move towards normalization
over another years but they everything
through these different people you can
borrow and course young kid like that
you mistreat them you make your guarded
very uncertain and you take away our
security problem then you can jump into
a complete neurotic lesson and deliver
recover and so this is hotel the same
applies for extraversion and disabled by
the conscientiousness and for real these
things are deeply deeply rooted people
people around the country but first of
all why would you accept a snake that
particular more person stable it's okay
that receives it and is useful to know
that any human violated that partly it
is not people cannot with you just
whatever thing you want to know if you
battled it find the dams off that you to
happen because easier contains your
camera to suit the job so if your is
bird and finally the conference's sales
know
and you're like a rad expert computer
programming problem here if you want
disorder run charities to all the other
programmers are going to help understand
the concerns of versions and they can
Sparkle it'll be all in work so go ahead
joke down people and so far away so our
context while terms of determine
predicts political belief their capacity
now at the local holy predicting say
party affiliation or voting behavior you
can get over 10% of the variance is with
the labels for seven-time like ostriches
planning to throw the less right because
you dig into a tiny tiny market success
in personal web but in your detailed
analysis of people flip away so
University how much farther than you
would with to be recorded behaviors even
get like 30 percent of the variance are
suspiciously power powerful enough to
making assumptions that the primary
determinant of politically is talent and
the primary determinants gentleman is
well and so you're biologically
[Music]
predisposed to be forever car as you are
now you might say well what about the
well-known phenomena where young people
can be more with all waiting in young
people older people density in a more
conservative part of the reason for that
is just people different audiences and
behave and so he had them stored
hypothesis at now it means none of
useful now yeah you're happy and you
talk to others right late not just
talking
why he is attacking the obvious person
the doctor probably different than you
and a reason but again it happens a
different niche in automata different
and has a real chance is real so here's
an example I could be trying to predict
also education for a long time let's do
it
course assessment and it's not obvious
who wanted printers are you know I make
you say this exactly so if they take
attachments any decisions in Israel I'm
saying that you heard the pastors are
artists it's not at all yet turned out
here as a start
so whatever serve treatment people
they're high in openness and what that
means is a gambler
coming up with new ideas and moving
sideways and really photography they
happen but they generally understood at
all ever economies but you want to run
company is overly conscientious and
non-sentient people will do what they're
supposed to do if they don't like it
then I'll jump all over the place they
want to track the walk down so I told
you have someone who saw the gas pipes
where it is not supposed to be any leaks
out of eyes they explode you want some
obsessive conscientious God you want to
get exactly right you want some cream by
welcoming like help serve others
and so on murders are a free event their
roles and managers and administrators
own a preservative and so you need
little place to start companies to be
creative and the zimmerit types to run
them as automatically know how many
creative artists need prepared holiday
20 realizes the same problem and how
many sales you need in the final scared
first public you service and a society
it has on circumstances
ok smell go with little more deeply so
can the predictors the hundred acres are
provably Oh gentlemen reserved for now
see that just lasted right I'll tell you
on the wedding to prototype smoke will
just make the conventional land right
distribution the right waiters are
locally openness that's the creativity
dimension like they can't predict a
parody Jesus burglary if you have he
uses fall you can wear a bra any Boston
many collections
guys in other words not a hack it won't
create a service will open up connected
high and conscientiousness and
conscientiousness fractionate into
industrious is an orderliness and
they're particularly high in the
orderliness
so that's a service not very important I
know connections here some of the
diesels let's say um ordinary
traditional hierarchical yell just
beautiful I came here to have
conventional now connected not some of
those things especially if you
traditional IRA still just do both party
is like as well you want to make an
order raw you know what our guys working
when we transfer on time so to speak
workplace to do with response of these
football or any block this one we're
excited in heavily on the boys now able
to order disaster sure and you can get
to anything that's the thing is it
happens at the end of these sacramental
distributions to Nora
not good to conscientious general normal
exercise they need to help needy
disorder to the variable for comment
motor self-inflicted my book
your residuals can't stand up for
yourself impersonation pressure and
eventually the wrong version that you
all great people take money happens
everyone ate our most basic impulses and
it is no hard rated in someone's panic
if they all want a clock and the whole
thing's a wonderful pleasure which is
nice pineapple but how we be we're told
as we notice if there are those equal to
x3 you can appendage are with you and
you always call attention people in here
like that so it's a great energy most
interesting last but some of you to
energizes like to make the decisions
when you're not happy and it's like no
how could you be practical you can run a
period no and that's what I'll be hating
them you know if you happy to happen so
you can if you can be too happy so you
know a set is any version she becomes a
life and afterlife jammer wolf
everywhere observe this past at all
right okay so if you think you got a
comedy morning or vomiting and resources
probably entrepreneurs need an answer
that is and some service man there isn't
an end
you can't say well you need like poems
in putting people in sixty percent
countries and recent exactly does
because environmentally jobs names and
it continues its judges eternal server
and your honor back you don't really
need to move and you fall off the job
for one last time
or inside you die so he produced a
approximately in middle and something he
didn't deserve but one time pulling you
pull and a little hard ever holding and
hope is by holding each other you say in
the name of dancing and then you take
off you decide a role and answer is well
I don't want the enemy to tell the other
person or question or give you any
competitors our maybe your head that
doesn't seem like very good so you begin
to that actually the problem trying to
solve and so even you can if you haven't
played to the other side you can impress
the other side you can fight at the
other side or or you can talk that's the
alternative you can talk if you're
talking with annoying people who aren't
liking it and one of the damages that is
those in the way people weren't like you
know things you don't know all those
people you get longer so well they're
already lie to you
you have a degree from them they just
tell the same things you know now that's
fine do you know where they need to know
so many by working so hard all whether I
mean whether or not you know everything
you need to know and I'm sorry
or you'll suffer so if you're saturated
and you are then I would suggest you
probably have some desire if you learned
in different axes are do not actually
why you learn and then everything well
since every word you know suffers the
last if you talk to someone who knows
the things you don't get then what else
to think you don't know and anything
will others of us and I enemy the
purpose of receipt okay so let's retired
now human genes after all
obviously life is tragic in short we
have a problem everyone home or people
have problems rich people
promise whatever they need imagine quite
a salad of social that perhaps among
Catholics as well is involved riding on
your resume 2° money to solve
fundamental human individual problems
it actually camp is opponents of this
values as a puppeteer is assistant
general Matthew why don't you make
enough money from you're not suffering
from absolute privation which means that
donor letters work cheesy from making
your life miserable then this one has
more that works on both of us and so we
hit that me yet we did bring up the
working-class stay and apply than that
yes my school for example because other
people relationship but as you get more
- done house what well I would let you
guys take a little bit you a little
longer anything it helps you the
ventilator for an instant here divorce
well along in your life does not be
necessary for the kids
no never pretended for diet for various
diseases but many my stand whether all
sometimes a lot of parts done
it's why do you solve the basic economic
problems as you do
Timothy once you have running water eat
shelter not food and access to a given
amount of information your audiences you
can be except to be better right you're
paying for all the artists all you
already hit the 90th percentile and they
wanted that I dine is my moral duty but
your multiple felonies and soul anyway
people - problematic right like acute
suffering but a fundamental rule and
another fundamental rule is if sagging
that collagen transcendent which is very
exciting
they're going to say Google what you
thinking so here now and save
over here is the employment in you're
not stupid
humming animals are unbelievably
insulting but it's not the same
intelligence that we have so the
mosquitoes alive new Java server to
explain an evidence from the scene is
talking about the dog it's all obvious
that whatever I needed let's make a good
hole the zero really no today's law
passed in the field and all right
everyone
and you'll need not only do not enjoy
Isola many many Castillo aids part of
the old way of thinking bringing to what
the schema joining produces small very
loud self and you are given supposedly
survived
they're slightly different and then
remedy here Walter wonderfulness Lysol
above he said once kill anyone that is
where he's knee-deep in school anymore
page named an amendment no time lock so
he offers much variance of himself than
was alive and then once do you listen
okay that's how they caught the a
consult your time so human beings weekly
you'd be on the thing when you're
married I need more sauce
dirty very number in rather the door saw
we were whatever into a and to do that
because our children are capable of
producing berries of themselves attorney
ever anymore so you need to play the
game out of are these are all that ever
my skill it'll pay home pleasure my dear
okay class or 90s and ideas avatar your
morale and even they bought this
organization and aesthetic because the
prefrontal cortex which is the whole of
your package they have started growing
out of the water for yet another
protective defending the name of you to
voluntarily move the north and somewhere
you do what you think is January after
our verses of yourself
test them in fictional environment they
are worse ones are stupid and likely to
die and then it's don't act those out
the map I have another but my life
the cynical person doesn't act out with
their stupidest ideas and so we've
internalized these are we develop we
think we produce narratives of ourselves
we tell them off ourselves and then we
implement the ones that we take our most
likely to survive pretty damn smart
so yeah but maybe have the nation's
reservations well I'm talking on one
camera you know your low personal moment
ago today the drives me crazy of
conservatives so conservative Hawaiian
to be week or so long I remember Harvard
this is only one the dummy said you
cannot help artists he completes help
they live in me harvest order what
sponging off the public person these red
artists like what three retarders did
you can write due to differences as an
artist in so close I love you
yes master artists even making on how to
survive in a bottle
there's no rich artist so but the
Conservatives they don't think they all
see Africa don't see the contribution
that harder to make you're blind you and
so I can give you example of how open
people were and how we contribute to the
public good if you made a block city
like will give you have to beat Ozzy
Harris it had a cool and don't people
role in it and we voted that the
frontier and I hope people don't hear
the Korean type staff and it is the from
here miss Rogers everywhere these
Parkinson scientist problems in a
thematic destruction literature the
sororities and states and abroad year in
cities where there's other markets that
order but this potential artistic types
knit that compartment they can only
portrays their system
I love you we go how we help you today
hey asleep institution is simple this
negative calories in any central coffee
shops many surgical things inserts PA :
let all the people crystal conical to go
and hang out in success cool man these
entrepreneurial times are certain north
and inner part the rotate and
anti-gentile
the other species rated own devices they
all have sanded off and improve saw
heart disease until thousand thirteen
people didn't compute has incredible
incredible value think about Europe Yugi
needs one pika to people who are cities
is utopia hobbies medicine a collision
circuit every European cities mammoths
were our areas and help us today about
100 millions of buildings as well as the
co-founder of the instead of the
organization you can call the return
investment that they gather you know I
mean places like France and Spain have
more to mislead people all the time
because people are going over the world
to bathe in your beauty of so it's
useful to talk to the old types and you
appreciate what they have for three days
you're blind my neck Conservatives be
little especially their low water than
us they can't even imagine diligence of
duty so imagine right leaders
traditional hierarchical knowledge in
typical horribly hygienic dirt animal
conventional narrative April by Jenny
under half of the first a tostop system
there are three people are very
sensitive to discuss and harder to read
about the Hydra conservative types are
exclusionary is because they were wrong
on themselves to pronounce integrity and
without notices reasons for that some
are very edges only can be are terrific
unfortunate for vomiting that layers
radical fluid mercurial careless chaotic
unsanitary
Callanetics all these the opportunity to
attend the representative which is
common to the part of the old sexually
transmitted diseases problem but you
know how many people can angel what
water noon and then hundreds a day I
would say so a lot of there's nothing
serious at bottom of these variances
there something damn series at bottom
and the real room for forums of informed
opinions all right so you want to do
certain attacks local open at a time for
instance why hot down there people do it
there live a traditional high work they
have golf instructors diligence in a
consultant Brandon a proprietary
the college consciousness is different
for every supinate dependent Arabs or
the toothinator demonstrated ability
it's not an IQ but at the next tested by
the motor case created
Russ organization open and actually
needed the correlative the Stargate
project as far as we can tell
decide is a lot mostly diligence
president that artistic besides of the
difference across source is the factory
to grind out the Spartan once again
so they're ready on why why with
openness conscientiousness go to get it
because under the political they're not
coordinating those strengths the Lincoln
real reason why you should quality
errors and eternal able to determine
critical thinking new fun thing about
this law I thought well I'm older people
they like let the jacket lost jumbo
gloss you know if they don't want to ask
to stay close they want on a possibility
off the spring out and so that you can
call days with it and it won't
conscientiousness devoted this tech
senses through our character border
statistics so on the one hand there are
created out some supporters and I'm
tightening that happens the
borders of turn Express again
and none of these well observe it if I
stare at hydro genese's
like daylight orders that order they
like to be protected partner
contamination and the more openness of
the Oh getting thrilled with jacket of
officer thought agency that they should
stay aloft we're too long symmetrical on
our interests chocolate networks every
single level of analysis it's like it in
certain types like the border around
concepts to remain tight identity
pretzel identities holds crime comedy
challenge problems space I thought that
would happen in the last election that's
what happened the trouble you can keep
saying this day long is about borders
collapses having your kids on board now
yeah that's right that's exactly as a
focus above its about borders between
things and these are you are - push it
towards the open on home and the answers
back again if you pay for the service
you can provide anxiety sermon come
looking for you turn and sometimes
here's what happens if you over the
border very sexy
max damn it so this is what happens to
Native Americans
they'll mortars let's head and the
president showed up what was in the
standings and show how 4th hole in law
and the social side particular time for
the Native Americans he conquered in the
entire territory is no man and over the
armor and the inning rally at that time
a soldier all that said but that wasn't
a problem
welcome visit the Santa Cruz Phillips
absolutely service but only European
city lovers of the time activity so cool
city living with our right foot disease
now you see so many colleges I adjust
these book report Allah if you division
check often isn't even a form of 50
worker you are rarely as hapless slow
nautical Americans not the Americans
not at all of harmony disease here so
the standard showed up nine hundred
percent of the Native American seven
right think about that so many have died
as an internist or dropped along by
mountainous and make sure that the
Native Americans are happy to see them
to didn't have the people take off the
cross definitely like the third dirty
five o'clock yet not a border security
if the last taken off the ships that the
sale of our third intercept of the page
bodies last leg but not when there is
95% it's like both of the board and see
what the hell happens is dangerous get
on the little web components yeah
say what is for me so yeah this
engagement close forward in old orders
Bobby will say that's if they can't see
that but if they were sending our usual
body argument that there's danger in
local Hortense Maude I think all these
goddesses hold the boards here today oh
my god man who thought here is our
relationship concludes the involved and
ability to eight originally and
prohibited by law Poland borders between
baby harvest between people in town for
babies is running into people having
some wrinkles are even stranger from
another culture and welcome in advance
of an El Rukn trades imagine all the
cool stuff
seven eight probably it because the
workers too tightly
they must and how it was going to say
that saying we're going to say from a
love the thing we're talking and then
the dance maybe can move the canvassing
a lot of us is in a hole like yes so the
services yeah overworked staff and the
middle setting close quarters get and
white both right that's the thing
they're both right and that's why we
talk to each other you see Kevin we
cannot figure out Jose an assessment of
the snake without talking well you've
got your biases your cognitive bias and
have built into you and so your blinds
in almost all the world and so you're
going to sit down thing and if you're in
thinking you actually break yourself in
down arms and you give all those out of
the borders and then you let them hash
it out and the wonder where you go so
even when you're thinking you're
basically engaged in violence it's just
giving me eternal but y'all hear thunder
less desert completely any problem off
because you are under the city they're
really juggling two through determines
and coaches and their diabetes and its
heart ladies ignoring its travel and its
canyoning interval requires creating you
have to be able to write that complete
clearly apnea formulated aren't you
happy with reg it's like it's really
hard to think so - bottle rebuilt in a
primary technical focus which is what
people do to 311 you can face to some
great work times the storms of gas and
everything you have going to some real
of you hello
thirty-four my experiment is now this is
part of my very people live longer
generic go on their forties because
they're different beginning but that's
so helpful as they have to brazen to
grade oxygen to do better than wondering
if the brains are communicating and
banks and differences really dependent
on just recently home so if I open
myself up with someone else and talk to
them games you dialogue then they'd be
correct here with a lot of thinking and
then breast over against that chance of
suffering and dying in so revision that
you have to be to not only because that
lives you out of your parochial deal boy
and helps you clarify the world and
correct in the world which is all these
different people that you have to be
lonely
that's hardly both of you survive just
in the world I mean in the sidebar here
is somebody who talked about moral
confusion I mean thinking Uncle Sam post
ornaments
pernicious horrible idea is that any cat
has an infinite number of potential
determinations and therefore there's no
becoming interpretation is correct not
talking about interpretation it in some
perverse sense is true if there are so
many phenomena that delay themselves
before you more that you can be serving
on the other way but give her the wrong
they say to the inert headed way in
every views in the world
anyway because the world like test if it
has instrumentation looking for the
wrong some of the dirt pages will kill
you some of those interpretations we
make you suffer some of the
interpretations will make people around
you solder front of information to
ladies will keep you from of
interpretation will make people refuse
to cooperate with you so then you say
well this multiplicity of
interpretations by us constraint over
the strategy of preserving yourself
preserving value-added relationships
preserving the growing social so coming
back go back you can imagine presumable
dollars you can definitely take my home
and baby
and also we lack in the actual world is
ever to slap you so hard about the state
that in Paris and so yes there are home
would be of interpretation
butter is a very tiny fraction of them
that actually have any
you till early so that undermines
completely that knowledge think the
argument related to multiplicity said
that of ages of postmodernist they know
effected a post-mortem is because that's
where they turn partisan Authority
results because you can't do anything if
your host Marcus because there's no
proper solution so anyway back to
receive yeah I think the jumping yeah
but reducing as a bar you should have a
lot of people you can tell one stupid
and then imagine our participants and no
dialogue of our line and envelopes you
talk to the ones in Osaka people
disagree with the burning things or do
things to say go you unless you're on
percent correct and I will be very very
hesitant about concluding that if your
skill properly unless you're under the
same correct then a know why have you
talking
it depends on or something else you take
you seriously serious seriously needs no
and it's all things how our culture
Western civilization that says roughest
evening and we couldn't talk to now you
know I'm really hoping it's not as
problems you can compare it to it how
does medical utopia is hell on our
computers and examine without an
ascetical people via actually tries to
manifest itself because then you find
out like however creative but that is
how these comparison sideways you
decided to turn light others decide an
accident well won't here before or they
want and it's where you know long ago
that tiny handful of countries that has
the latency
that's tightly associated first date
what basically he can solve problems you
have
we got a lot of meetings although why if
we things are proud you figure out that
there's nothing more important than free
takes an active thinking is that's the
locals is it at the bottom or cultivate
the Divine Word the transforms pay off
his order continually and off you mark a
path not initially precisely you do have
been able to participate that by
engaging in conversations communication
with others soul and also set you
straight
and if you're not afraid then you suffer
die and so we regret and maybe you're a
bad luck you play that out but if you're
not and if you really have you really
think through some people have gone
through is included that it was like
being if it has to be would work to
bring it to a halt Meghan Arizona I
think it's a terrible case I think is a
profoundly flawed case because it's
predicated on the idea that you've
already done everything you could to
improve things and you have so I could
say well before you transform yourself
into the element of judgment being you
should try practical to country and see
if you can prove things around you these
are surrendered your final judgment and
how we do that
well this utility or something what do
you don't not now that's why these are
pulled to left tricep let the others not
going as well before you had a big for
me and I'm going well for your family as
they cookies or your community or your
country for the world we eat those
have your problems you can be trying so
many honest couple are these are salt
that another person
regula sees are you trying to solve with
all your heart and mind and soul and as
bad no I think our state wasting time is
the standard and you don't know where
they say to do is that sardine archaea
and so seven dragons from late last and
hair as a right to spots is that where
you see property Wars being and then
being humble know if you don't have your
act together that makes you open your
eyes if they thought is modeling they
don't going online is stupid and there's
people to different for me maybe if I
talk to them listen mostly that you
would believe what people would label
tell you what you live just absolutely
unbelievable what the hell there are
thousands of hours of experiences every
people some focus groups like is a
doggie asking all over and over once you
get about your ecological
presuppositions when they start talking
about the realities they're actually in
contact with their endlessly revealing
and remarkable and you learn and there's
a lot of time you can exhibit what
Disney lattices you're not very smart
and you're solving it so you don't you
can learn something from someone
especially someone different in you for
the day the name masses expression name
so okay so back to that wing well
masculinity I don't want so the Korean
folks are Illinois they're nice and
chaotic or the Bar Association you know
interesting distance for all levels
themselves but sound employment-based I
believe because I don't need that and
then so they're going to district didn't
conservatives well I know blinders on
that they're just not that excited and
he rolled his age and remark evening and
I'm an orderly and these are the
descendants or any like things to stay
where they are so now that goes from the
partly it's like whatever you've done
well given their your people and you
know they're going to people that you
want to be they're like your
hypodermic needles for example so let
you know the person on the political
distribution and the health exams need
to communicate sailor faculty and say
okay so can a quote with over more
elaboration on the lasting rationales
for free speech for you
this or great has something like free
speech is being used by fascists tool
press impressed or are the flippity
Brett radical leftists or arrogance give
used to oppress will oppress got one
size fits all solution everything is
cooking intellectually its power in the
world and I thought there's just too
easy but I one-sided you press that
means universes it's like not doesn't
resolve what you can think you're on the
side of the oppressed
really you really dare to claim out it's
not so easy to be on the side of the
oppressor it needs to have a lot of work
to be honest I did you impress and wave
you cider from the Vegas table is you
thinking hey sack not be notified alas I
don't know whether the
and while your father was one come on
crazy idea such as Ramzi going on -
Keith and his cause tool called summer
and all quite raisins with a navigating
it out of it to make amenity now he
tells self an accountant
if job I think I got word that there are
some monstrous got become didn't there's
no article in this newspaper finals
professor said that I recommend was
inviting your company than I was making
the space unsafe as you can tell is
unfit to top-secret addition to get
loans to get bone mallet now and so are
again you know start annoying sorta to
see those off the Linfield College to
violence basis things
your soul and that soul they're not
really fresh beginning all the people
who should be in favor of free speech
it should be equal to our hypothetically
on the side of people press y ou rather
African tradition is everything to
hydrazone the patriarch and the people
let's talk with all the power
okay when the people talking para ella
walk and they lock in the newspapers and
TV stations the only other person is the
old corporation say if they fight they
want whenever they will just be
protected obviously there will power and
give you from bringing back the awful
framing right a huge connection is they
wanna see for me the people tomorrow
tomorrow
okay so let's review the evidence social
workers at the 20th century whether I
remember speak truth to power of ELISA
yes you can see ten stitches up a
definite P operon decal power say hey
lucky go ha my boy a wonderful and now
you get out where the one you don't want
to hurt enormous and anybody's in the
show ball these are my disasters and
final novels and
have doctors like dr. kieny is like that
not all the way because there's
different social critics in home
so what your features are in here do you
see a transition so hold your left
earlier you want to plan out vehicle is
rolling and you think well geez I'm
going to get more of it please anything
well what let's just rip Reese's and
anything here is if I can from the
military if you may go back with me 11
we have 11 16 years so you know if the
logical conclusion to that or something
like comedy slightly carry luggage
weapons given it and it's so black the
last for the free speech term haters
quick you guys are the ones who think
that everyone else has the power
you start restricting free speech what
are you doing
you need Radley's continually not a song
but you think firm on that those people
have the power and if sa the colored
people who have the power just to
clarify you think that they're not going
to be a hell out there that between
really quick here so blogging on even
disability despite its identity those
every single whether you use to a
prosperous piece is going to be aimed
back you enforce it depends and as and
so many wonderful people reversing is
less prevalent are naive is that all or
the naive or are a willfully blind or
are they actually below but they
actually aiming at trouble now although
with 19 you get better the simplest
explanation but a rule of the other
books all right so let me look at the
20th century suffragettes Buddhist rites
are back above it
freedom of speech legalese fully and how
II do not want the legacy in stored out
of that remember
de creme speak of their right for
laughing the Nexus the Nexus of
residences well known however our
constitutional protection for three
mistakes starting in a absolute gracias
versus it repeat move apart in a
explorers you see what a bird fly over
the ban on non-standard countess
political activities until the students
for the right to free speech that man
freedom anyone well they were professors
here on the level of those people right
there already a life is a zero included
in general readers the students movement
in here in any one movement to other
news where CN more risky we're about a
mile implement our LGBT movement who
knows might depend on free speech for
all these ladies were to use the power
marginalized people all they had their
capacity this barbarian argument to make
it half that it in a place right ready
they have power that's a very plain so
what power they have theirs how to see
your no matter has power is real power
and so we choose a normal size of
Gilcrest love you claim then you should
be standing up as diligently as you
possibly can for free speech because
it's the most powerful lesson you have
to write the societal norms that you're
hypothetically and perhaps realistically
concerned about it we have a deception
equality for example we haven't
discussed it long enough until we figure
out how to saw everything from stacking
optical image distribution and
everywhere else getting zero and this is
a problem so a family this has both lies
there does not horizontal ease but
they're not sin did you know you may
notice that their goodwill comes because
they're building robots and robots from
robots are first going to take the shape
of a car but an autonomous part is no
more car than a card with a horse-drawn
carriage they're not the same thing
they're not even close to the same thing
and they're going to crucify
transformations that are so radical if
you're an animal but I become one of the
transmission is going to occur
what's the most common source of
employment for man in North America
brighter right and so one of the
autonomous robots show up it would be
very long than what most people ones
didn't and wizardess they're going to
stack up into zero and that is already
happening in the United States in
particular anything Tomas tell me not
for Trump on lacquer right because the
gamma Democrat your absolute stupidity
abandon the working class who get
important to represent well it's not
whether they're going to be business
best people it's going to be a big
problem and you need to figure out how
to solve it and so we need an active
black eagle Evan actually stands for not
so smart in a not guarantee Vil
murderous reprehensible Marxism like
that happen go
right touch of Taranaki that means be
trickling but anything that machination
is the other and then when you come
straight and after you're making
conversation XE and there are students
that are made in students they were
professional tested ice and if they
would soon as they haven't been educated
budgetary possibly huge oxidative engine
what's attention up top and that they
showed up with a big banner it had a
hammer and sickle all looks like what
the hell it is not funny it's not funny
the sickle monkey needs to cut off
people's heads
what happened attorney essentially is no
solitary children but we're going to get
you saw what not to really deal with all
that Americanism but boy it is always it
is we see plenty examples of real
confidence that's all I was saying no
never tell believers the circumstance
are only because people will no more
bear to go to a protest with a bloody
hammer sale the name dare go in not the
uniform
one in five social scientists in
universities identify themselves as
Marxist like why the hell is that
accepted whatever take for us to learn
will obviously a couple hundred million
yes and the Cold War at the threat of
nuclear
servants
what not what what is English the metal
box motivation to have done
trying to get the model things how
innovative that there's certainly to the
million of the eternal human soul now
the whole metaphor if you want and five
networks comes the assertive health
debate but then I thought how is this
old photography satellite and other
industries is X right well indeed either
the prophetic voice some hunting both as
a Jewish conceptualization Oracle over
and what is that well it's the voice it
restructures in equitable social society
that's the prophetic for you and the
heart that transforms the payoff of
potential was very very roundness
inhabitable order and the manner in
which that soul manifests itself so the
society can be guided by it is firming
down through communication term free
speech and so the put a limitation on
that is to other limitations I would say
the Holy Spirit itself and that's the
sin that cannot be forgiven and so I can
say wake up start allowing people to do
this they are no one's planning left
right whatever in terms of the bottom to
do is dependent on your ability to
communicate what you believe as clearly
as possible if you're totally duty to do
and anyone who interferes with that
interferes with the proper involvement
of being is up and it is a catastrophe
that at the moment the University in
general and the humanities specifically
are the world students
so when it's time for our Q&A so pure
VIP ticket holder you get back to the
questions before any holes
they had a doctor buted and swapper tell
me you're awesome
we all loved what you've done yeah we've
launched a great accord I don't actually
have much this winter give you the
comment on tons of before and after of
your life from a point where you did
that video games political pregnant if
you just want to tell a little anecdote
or a little story of Evelyn kind of in
the days before - you got elected human
and your stance for that Pokemon when
you do that well the first part mostly
assume you I think is rightly funny me
so how do Jamie is surreal album
overhaul how I needed hideous and Adam
said I hate them what hard I'm old and
dirty
you want to say that's a party I love
and I started Torian usually right I
have a minute exposure on how the felony
in Ontario and a year here go on has
being constant and so I know those are
regions and tell people cost a little
bit and then I start my second document
about that school audience participant
egos an absolute pain for his boss mm mm
it's a brighter side marketers like
almost empty degree Bernardo need years
by that they own national examination
accountant our experience about how
creative people with all types of our HR
people interested in our government 4.17
to do that as you get involved in
regulating really learn how to do it
sorry that setup and I notified on my
killing him if I were you I'd walk a
thousand subscribers good luck not a lot
I don't want to be in half I so what we
sold nearly coffee we are being touched
our cameras in there you have a very
lacking energy content as over ins and
gender are over I think our political
carcass Recaro a variable it's published
in February called 1212 a better word
both problems light and agile
scale assess if I only did one of those
jobs is called Charles called Beaumont
on the state morning and any public
affairs and preserving obscenities you
know she did manage to take of life and
about news how this bill TTC then I read
investigated I don't have a type of
client with a German beyond the limit of
Tolerance ugly
it would work like we were drafted to
have a sensible people and all
everything yellow dust and rock anyone
and I need a higher energy healthy video
to look like a little gratitude you know
it all just happens is going to make it
mandatory for their Human Resources
people to rather know has unconscious
bias training societies River is a
target when we use F of Y of Duty 16
secret enemies and wealth and vibrant
and for sportsmen and no I'm good later
I thinking and I thought that people
walking and then seeing 14 see that and
some of its great but this is great
sorry is also great you know it was very
autism for the multi months all thing I
would say on behalf of my family
he headed my mom was in Germany they're
very I got my to one legs from
universities with bullabbai most
ambitious initiative and I know how
companies were very support networks
entirety moment then realism morning and
then they got definitely really going
down the eat our path and then push they
would continue going down he set up a
lot of the sport and to begin with with
the journalists they know whether on
with you Adebayor good guys and here not
but some of them actually read to the
territory to lady on the handle of the
bar oh he's actually didn't tell people
what actually
nice and we were journalists so three
thousand my spoon and to be more
concerned about greasy animals and so
when ambassador was started acting my
failure then it's also Thomas workers
rather goal because they came up the
crispy strong against a variety of
cynically
not strategically viable safe this is
like a I think sitting on the hard way
every time that those observers we're
not me I understand that you have to
develop yourself and that comes from
using Express do we have what do that
for example a place I could just impact
that the performance will hurt because I
use it I remember people that watch it
little carried our summer PBSO life
great I both of the rabbit just surreal
I no idea where is Bill oh I don't
really have any on Google attack
it's fair to tell for me take the car
loan with an office but I didn't need it
the found an end level analysis sweet
are so good at the deepest doesn't feel
awful that so soft when having you laugh
somewhere between philosophical feel of
we're going to price the negative go
away your lip and I'm hoping that they
go forever and I'm hoping is going to do
it is accelerating on eternity there
gerald
Forte
and then close inside one final answer I
learned a long time ago that there are
too many of propelling yourself to life
one is you decide you want you to legs
to get that all headed is not doing
anything even pretty good in your love
except that baggage much New Zealand was
given one okay another you used to - to
state what you observer and
conceptualize as clearly as you possibly
can and let over hiding is going out to
that what I try to do is so difficult
happened and unamended he's okay with me
he said I already decided that whatever
now someone I'm doing that was revealed
a macrophage activate action because you
decided that the world rundown on truth
was offered here on federal return as a
decision and deserted and let Horace
Hall where the ball and so I'm watching
where the ball and I'm trying to stay in
half and so far for me so hey
people past nine versus maybe both let's
let's make a little because people
wanted to what to help so we want so how
are you but how did it it's almost time
only Howell is out there because I will
be accountable after open dialogue being
the only things that help keep
communication between two the groovy air
view point how you connect the people
who are equated certain words are fine
okay so first of all I would say vision
as difficult as right so there's an
analogous problem in criminal psychology
which is how are you sure to help
someone who doesn't want to be else can
answer it I can easily distant quote
against that another harsh one little
cat girl with before swine totally a
long time of these imitated and what it
means is that you develop what's
valuable by offering it to people who
will not appreciate if you can begin a
dialogue for summer they don't want
someone who's having a development and
maybe enticing what about those people
an understable the best interview with
them vertices you have an inverted desk
and the second answer is the only way
that you get a person out of a cell
phonee health is by example so you walk
away from people you cannot communicate
with creative people who you can
communicate with you recognize you learn
and then and then hope that some of the
break up some of the well yeah
our repeaters thank you very much for
your speech is fantastic my person is
very simple it has to do with your
funding of academic research which you
recently did on IndieGoGo for error
I believe in the political correctness
and you raised a more than double so far
your original goal it's now at one
hundred sixty two thousand dollars which
is amazing and I hope the organizers of
this event will post the links we can
get more money and by the question is
this is the first time I've ever seen a
university research being funded by the
public at large as altitude we want to
be creating Research Council's which
usually are just committee innocent
children comedians like as president
setting it's not remembering how do you
think this will change the pattern
research funding in Canada well that's
good question these things I have a
heart of personal that's all my campaign
right it's the remedies now they have
big money and I said yes but I I don't
believe I would have done it on my own
you can seem like now what what is it
seem like it seems in some kind of like
capitalize no misfortune no and so
fighting it so they didn't and happy
with that but when I talked to a number
of people than I do how what is
concededly me and one of the things that
we thought about was saying opposite of
where my other professors could do the
same thing other researchers now
gorgeous
I think in one whole experiment calm I
planted right margarita and that was
finally sort of thing it might be weird
and then getting whether this is setting
a renewable and private residence but it
isn't obvious to me that I have the time
to indefinitely never long enough to
figure out how to do it and that is part
of them trying to they are right now so
I'm going to be talking to people of the
next problem on oral argument I have
some some supporters who are reasonably
well capitalized and they are interested
in working to allow that sort of thing
to happen but it's very complicated and
I am I'm already occupied and so I have
Ganz's I don't know what sort of
president was that I do know that it's
going to keep my graduate students
working for the next three years so with
a lot of my curve in the graph it's all
and again and then I'll have more money
and I would and that funny so I hope
I'd like to thank you for posting your
videos the lectures on the onion part
sites present lianting is worthwhile if
anyone's interested my person knows
about the limits and restrictions on
free speech so honestly are opposed to
anyone whether it's free speech however
how do we feel the issues like death
threats or honest or pernicious to
advertise yeah are using the order Delta
peppers makes it like there are there
are limits to purchase these to be I
think English home of all actually felt
separately I'm a great admirer English
common law and which I want to be
involved be consistent rights of to some
Republicans you should because our legal
system is become powered up by these
what you call intermission of French
civil law precepts is being this called
law system which is its capacity in my
estimation under English law yet all
right there are there are Brandon to you
by the body you have and then what's
happening is on laws we heal us right
Cyrus right having been scrapped because
you know gonna wear one like nvm we
begin so they may be to the court and
then the court decides roughly speaking
where the line is drawn and then in the
law whole organically across time and
having haven't had a comical person be
involved limitations on I would say
first speech decisive and I don't really
believe that that's what they are but
you get out of death threats so and I
guess it's part of the paranormal
situation where sometimes what you're
doing with your free speech is
interfering with the continuation of
free speech in which case you should be
saw it's something like that and so you
know there should be there some
seditious speech of some sort because
that's pretty simple speech you know
again if what you're doing it oriented
towards demolishing the structure upon
which your own freedom
and then someone has to be there at the
Elizabeth where then does it should be
blown up stuff s by law order g7 Iran
take care deference Canada size in
criminal activity right you can't blame
rely for commercial blender yeah the
doctor from sample is MC certain
discrete Courtney left you haven't put
more luggage back across that has
compelled the Beast which was what I was
objected to ability 16 but I was hired
the commercial domain they're having to
be any attempt to compel speech and that
function so I think those things have to
grieve development on a case-by-case
basis because the Devils in the detail
and I also like the English home law
such a staggeringly brilliant
combination the world culture and it
will paint both is ready to order
yeah most countries that were founded on
English called the law are rich divided
in the Americas on my ranch or farm I
horrible for our birthdays poor con
vitamin rich in control and the legal
structures now it's not all focus is
great book home this is called the
wealth and poverty of mages is written
by Harvard emeritus professor Keith and
lies he was really curious about why
some countries in the Americas
withholding some of it
they all have natural resources and
that's what's wrong and so on then how
to market like Japan it would even over
for resources and the rich harmful
illegal to do this is the element in
Action News opens thanks for going to
yes love Louis Vuitton Marxist
conception of fuel now like animal eat
it but over there you know I know
so why can't be subjective I see an
illusion and still fit into your
methodological perspective well Jesus
bring about a question like that this is
the truth this is the truth about any
question like that when you say is a
equipment to be the Empress depends on
Finance for them sometimes be like so
people answer in some sense or exactly
the correct answer because a hands a
question without knowing what you
specifically mean by entities and
specifically meaning office objective
are now and I want to say the person not
formulated focus the eye is referring to
is not homogeneous heterogeneous there's
a multiplicity of eyes you know changing
some of my energy with something like a
unique out of law and some of that
appears in some senses when you do see
it in the same way that the dancehall on
your computer it will lose your
representation of the actual
computational process it's not loser in
that it's functioning into thinking
about illusion at some see you have to
define the metaphysical arena in which
you were for
the contest before we have a proper
discussion of them now having said all
that I would say my simple truth that I
am here to invent civilizations that act
out of the human being that free world
seem to work now that's apart not a bit
evidence it's not a scientific
dependence but on readiness 2000 through
body and soul I'm sure it has the second
I would say well if something is aren't
you and it based on the particular first
temple that an opera circle is true
enough and that's what I think about
free will and not if he's looking at the
soul no I'm not going to God constant
exhausted analysis of free will for of
the soul is but it's a good first
approximation
I think that I find when you're two days
I know this isn't to underlays but it's
probably we keep it Leonard you said
that you're a big fan of a guilty
pleasure for trailer park boy you give a
brief sort of article title on your
haircut and we just tie back to free
speech how a show that is so crude and
offended misbehave you look
many reasons for working here baby math
mama come the thread of our
correspondence
why do I later remembering a word I
don't know if you know the movie fubar
I like football exactly both the people
that I broke with would let me be grabs
you devotees have a great time
what floor are you from eight years ago
they have my old friend someone over and
like be vertical smokiness and there's
something about our working class of
diet I think they're funny and pretty
good humor and something I really miss
I'm coming all the way this
working-class guys to peak is through
modernity and the organization has hired
love broccoli young range remember
things and what he started a lot of
situations I got in there observe been
given and the gentleman is a great
example that I think
hilarious fun but I also like multi
revoir boys and that's all talk citizens
is absolutely reprehensible in all the
details a separate container house
intentions family is central to the
distance right we'll have one disabled
over like blah family's amazing for
Salman and fundamentally they're
oriented towards each other and how it's
always a comedy because they're not and
so that that is the assassinates
assistance just not mean-spirited
rocking spirits great shot
everyone's a home to Jill and the
characters are are essentially hard and
it's the same sub less degrees it might
be necessary
we have work with different well two
things it's about impulsive mail stupid
but comfortable friendship and reinstall
friends even the enemies are friends and
so they created exact I've done this
remarkable job walking the line between
satirical maybe just meetings it's great
at heart but they have a love their
characters and hope for the characters
you know they're completely forever
animal right so that's right I like the
different I always wrinkles - because I
think you're unbelievably poisonous you
want to still have these documentaries
like out there
my family - these are real pizzeria
[Music]
multi-episode down houses
I have a wife list watch this one I
wanted to recreate an alternate party I
have a question about your claims on
political beliefs and their correlation
to shape our personality I mentioned
that there's truth angels be fighting it
out in this between the right and left
what do you make of crafts recipe wishes
what I see emerging the libertarian
agenda she's a good English February
yeah the first answer is I don't know
how about dinner cherries to say because
they're not the only video is happening
on the pianist and now I should say that
the putting Socratic lights are not
positive disorder with those that they
distinguish or for the politically
correct Isis with a very high in grills
and Mike's a Volvo c30
Audrey of people are only agreeable with
a like so if you're in than half then
your name
but if your own going to that Sanders
name and so they're very agreeable thing
but they're not very agreeable to say
and most people are snakes hold so the
libertarian my suspicion is there I am
openness and high and conscientiousness
I don't know I really don't know they
may also Marcus bear is agreeable
because they're kinda like eating a halo
effect and those are people that I I'm
agreeable on quite agreeable you can
guess that sometimes I fight it really
hard but you'll get agreeable type
spaces we come to screw off and doesn't
be real useful because I meant that is
what we should do I suspect if you they
are off their chairs or more disagrees
- so you're some concern about losing
your job of viewers who trauma and I was
just wondering given that your page
around come excuse my own celery is
there a threshold at which you would
consider resigning and pursuing YouTube
just being a person youtuber as your
memory well you know I thought about
that but as I said earlier I think to do
both things at the same time and right
now does mobians me that means I have
rely on wellness nutrition professor and
I should also say on behalf of students
but look I went out contagion January I
was not a very good shape I had real
health crisis in December which I think
was unrelated to this year do not but
but I was really going to good shape and
I I have been it has been recommended to
me by my chair that I'm not return to
teaching independently of what was going
on at the Bursar's but there's no damn
way because I just like no but I over
there to be how much additional scraps
or guilt all of the sins were
extraordinary low animal distinct at
university drop em all students a
competitor if you see most of our kids
are first-generation immigrants right
like in Iran a bloody political bad way
is to serve afraid another economic
future if they're powered by the dreams
and desires of in Paris and I'm looking
those elders in the cell phones that
elbow trying to get integrate about here
to function so I like the residence now
there's a small percentage of the
exporters all the same damage third
No
centers not only companies and their
students without another net the
administration a fair number of
societies who are politically correct of
the university itself you can actually
create conservatives in the small C
sense not annoying sometimes because I'm
quite radical from a creative
perspective and so I reacted there
someone constraining whatever I got
nothing to complain about as University
professor it's a highly higher privilege
on your own to have I'm lucky data and
order that I like teaching young people
it's a great privilege to do and so I
hope being reason to stop and I have
every role we have so far as working so
as longer I'm glad alone which is my
literature massage is long enough long
go to university and I generally and
then I can have my cake and eat it too
and so that's a good deal
[Music]
oh so earlier this each and you
mentioned how the left generally kind of
come to a view where they perceive as
oppressed right so I've told you to the
right as being sort of oppressed unlucky
myself do you think my recession is
correct and if so what do you think that
is social justice type don't also see it
like I did yeah well you know we're in
the time with cat right is nothing in
this chaotic times things reverse and
twisting and and were detailing times
and I believe that our everything I do
believe that's partly why this main part
of a word come into left the Pratt the
right
and I think it's more like the left as
being Dracula as being in tremendous
control over many institutions as a
consequence of inappropriate public
session so they're not that many but
there are whole disciplines that are
pathologically any order to that it was
just like the ethnic studies women's
bodies pryzwarra studies in particular
complete houses and increasingly the
humanity to be coded up for guess the
health authorities a difference the way
down to Marxism underneath that the
problem ended that set up a system where
people on that orientation can draw a
single cell forget this thousands of
hundreds of thousands perhaps and do
nothing but work on are they they are
working on which is the underlining of
the patriarchy which is a recommendable
term ugly its embargo oversimplification
obviously and is also profoundly
unreadable because both the patriarchy
is an impressive structure obviously
because any social community requires
conformity or non social community it's
also staggeringly productive and for
example provides them with a degree of
safety and security that's unthinkable
well they perceive their fifth called
gender reversal is not successful and
blameless offered an artist Harris don't
let your children paste humanities
courses and
one of the things that our position of
doing system and this would be very
proud services projects are going to
make a technical complexity mechanical
analysis of postmodern flash Markus's
slot social justice terminology
receivers the rental rates and then race
course descriptions the apprehension
rate 5 through 7 and puzzle and so
Hendricks brain horror universities and
colleges our social justice infiltration
and and producing a manual or pair of
high school students a who not to be a
person in which horrible because I think
that starving the mouse is the right
approach and it could be difficult
because behavior and that under the
murder and resistance on Cypress their
way of exploiting it and be exploited I
mean the other nominee you guys all real
peer-reviewed ten I pretend I'm on
Twitter then you want to see what the
powerful humanities scholars are up to
you subscribe the real be relieved that
is like you is far more observant on you
so I basically it is select a person to
write and in my retinas while the lefty
is oppressing the universities and the
universities are crediting Macaulay now
whether that and my friend wakes and
some degree into what you described so
this one is the on behalf of the UBC
through speech Club we just want to
thank everyone for coming out and we
want to thank dr. Henderson coming as
well for those as we hope you take
something tomorrow where we will be
doing the devouring mother event that
will be a joint conversation between dr.
Peterson and Carrie Myers right there
and that going to be live streamed as
well a lot of this one and that's going
to be on Aaron media for now and you
know that you want to copy that so
that's going to be on your channels and
eventually and what are those lips yeah
and the rows you have the apt-get Obama
softly yeah thanks for coming out
you